and finally new rule blind hatred of
america
is just as blinkered as blind love
and we and we americans
should really get some perspective about
where we live
watching the [ __ ] go down in afghanistan
i was reminded lately of every
conversation i've ever had with an
immigrant almost all of which if we got
to really talking included the notion
oh you people have no idea
all you do is [ __ ] about and bad-mouth
your own country but if you knew about
the country i came from
you'd stop [ __ ] on your own
now
right
i have never been a rah-rah america type
and in fact have often made fun of
republicans in the past for being overly
sentimental
because they're the ones who tear up at
military flyovers and get a boner when
the governor of south dakota rides into
a biker rally dressed like a painting at
teddy roosevelt
john boehner used to cry
cry like [ __ ] weep
at the drop of a hat if anything
reminded him of what a star-spangled
miracle this country is if there was a
little flag in his club sandwich he'd
lose it
it's just in the conservative dna to
have this dewy eyed sloppy drunk love
for their country that often renders
them incapable of acknowledging its
problems that's how we got the 2013
supreme court ruling gutting the voting
rights act
not because john roberts is a monster
but because people like him tend to over
romanticize america he thought the south
was ready for the honor system they
weren't
but
but liberals as usual in this era have
now gone too far in the other direction
they under romanticize america they have
no perspective
last week the taliban murdered a
comedian
his name was nazar muhammad and he made
up funny songs on tick-tock they forced
him into a car tortured and then
executed him a comedian
a thing like that hits a little close to
home for me
i've had two presidents up my ass
this one warned me to stop speaking my
mind
they need to to watch what they say
watch what they do and this is not
a time for remarks like that there never
is
and this one sued me over a joke
[Music]
and as president called me every name in
the book for the crime of predicting
he'd do exactly what he did
this crazy
bill maher this idiot comedian these
people are sick he's a great lunatic
he's a whack job he is a total nut job
yeah i mean
neither experience was pleasant but i
didn't have to worry about being dragged
till i'm dead behind a toyota tacoma
have a little perspective about the
stuff we howl about here
i'm
i'm sorry your professor said something
you didn't like that won't be a problem
with the taliban because you're not
allowed to go to school
in saudi arabia grown women can be
jailed for doing the kind of things we
think of as routine without the
permission of a male guardian
china rounds you up if you're the wrong
religion and puts you in camps
more children in burkina faso work than
are in school
only five percent of burundians have
electricity
the homicide rate in honduras is eight
times what it is here the inflation rate
in venezuela is
and nineteen 2719
the philippines in the last five years
has put to death twenty seven thousand
low-level drug dealers my old job
in north korea people starve to death
the only people who starve here are
doing it for a role
and the only people who have no water
live in california
if you think america is irredeemable
turn on the news or get a passport and a
ticket on one of those sketchy airlines
that puts its web address on the plane
there's a reason afghan mothers are
handing their babies to us
and
and we should take them americans right
now should take in afghan refugees into
their homes and into their neighborhoods
and i'm sure everyone who just clapped
is thinking the same thing yes someone
who isn't me should definitely do that
but that doesn't make us the bad guys
we're not the bad guys oppression is
what we were trying to stop in
afghanistan we failed but any immigrant
will tell you
we've largely succeeded here
and yet the overriding thrust of current
woke ideology is that america is rotten
to the core irredeemably racist from the
moment it was founded and so oppressive
sexist and homophobic
we can't find a host for the oscars or
jeopardy
oh yeah
i'm sure you heard the new jeopardy guy
is out because he said boobies in 2014.
and this is where your new afghani
roommates that you took in
will
will
will prove so valuable because they'll
turn to you and say have you people lost
your [ __ ] minds
have you
have you ever heard of honor killings
public beheadings throwing gay men off
of roofs
arranged marriages to minors
state sanctioned wife-beating female
genital mutilation marriage by capture
because we have
what's the lesson of afghanistan maybe
it's that everyone from the giant dorm
room [ __ ] session that is the internet
should take a good look at what real
oppression looks like
ask your maid
ask your uber driver ask the asian woman
giving you a massage
she'll tell you this place is shangri-la
and not just because she works in a
place called shangri-la
america
may not be the country of your faculty
lounge and twitter dreams but no one
here tries to escape by hanging on to an
airplane
no
we wait till we're inside the plane to
fight
and then only because they cut off the
beverage service
you